if i'm not mistaken and i could be wrong
about this you worked on the star wars
prequels as a visual effects
person you did visual effects
one two and three yes you can see my
names in the credits
so this has to be a little weird for you
because you're probably the only person
who did visual effects back then who is
now a voice on a star wars anime
can you sort of talk about this
yeah no it's not really weird it's just
cool you know it's like i went to
ireland because i love star wars and
yeah i was secretly hoping i'd get a
role in star wars and now comes full
circle you know uh it just took like an
emmy and globe nomination to get there
but uh i it was just amazing to be part
of this and ironically like all the
people who were my bosses at ilm or like
my colleagues you know i was talking to
them it's like oh my god i can't believe
you're in this when we saw your name we
were super excited and like everyone at
lucasfilm was happier you know i was
happy it was it was just like a love
story
so definitely a dream come true
i i can't even imagine um how much did
they tell you actually about your
episode uh when they offered it to you
and how much were you like wait i can be
a voice in star wars just tell me where
to sign the latter uh
as you know with disney everything is
super confidential so they don't tell
you anything
but except like oh this is part of the
star wars franchise and we're doing this
like i'm in that's all you had me at
star you had me a star that's all you
need so
uh then how excited were you when you
found out um jedi lightsaber uh and
everything that was going to be
happening it was you know like isn't it
always like a kid's dream to want to
hold like a lightsaber and for me you
know i studied kendo because i i got
inspired by all the you know
you know the the you know the jedi
fights and we all i remember always like
afrikaner practice we take those you
know shin eyes and practice pretend we
were like willing lightsabers so to be
able to do that now even though
virtually was like uh it was just
totally awesome
how much of you i don't know if you know
anyone at consumer products at disney
but i'm just curious if you've happened
to try to send them any emails or
letters explaining that how your
character should have an action figure
and everything else
that would be amazing and stephen if you
can help uh begin that movement i would
greatly appreciate it i will sign
right i i don't i only know some of the
the sideshow people but uh you know i
think disney has to do some sort of
authorization um you know there's a
little bit more to it um what um i am
i always like learning about the behind
the scenes of the making of anything
what do you think might what do you
think maybe would surprise people to
learn about the voice recording process
for something like this
this was actually a very interesting
process because it was originally dubbed
uh originally i recorded in japanese and
we were doing the english dub so it's
the first time i've ever had to
dub a japanese voice and the japanese
voice acting is very different from the
english voice acting so it was really
really interesting to be part of that
process a little bit of a learning
process as well
well that's i've watched a lot of
japanese anime and it is a completely
different um i can't obviously
understand japanese but it's very
different the inflections and where the
emotion is placed um at least it appears
that way to me being an ignorant
american um uh i'm just curious if you
could sort of talk about did you try to
mimic anything from those voices do you
know what i mean
yeah i mean there's definitely
differences cadences especially if you
try to do humor you know the timing is
very different and you know we're trying
to lip sync to the mouth you know
because they've already uh you know
they've already synced it to the
japanese uh
original japanese lines but but because
i understand japanese fully i speak it
you know fully so i try to mimic that
same tone but this is different because
the word choices are different and where
you put the accent on where you put the
emphasis on so those choices were so
were very very different and us as
actors you know especially mostly being
on on camera a lot we tend to try to
keep things a lot more naturalistic and
throw things away so which is very
different from anime voice acting so
it's it was really interesting to like
figure out you know and and talk with
you know the the director there to
figure out like okay this is what we
want to do this is what we want to keep
the essence of you know and there wasn't
much you know we can't really improvise
as much on an anime side so uh whenever
when you're syncing to animation stuff
so i don't know it was it was really uh
it was really fascinating and i
now that i know what to expect i would
love to do it again
my last question for you uh i'm kind of
excited for a film called bullet train i
think it's directed by a david leech um
yeah hypothetically there's some stars
you know um but uh so i have to ask you
um because i believe you're part of it
what the hell is it like being part of a
film like that what can you say about
your role uh
it was an amazing experience um and just
during code times to be able to shoot
something of that magnitude and like
scale is
it was just a godsend it was just so
much fun doing it it's all i can say and
it's a it's definitely going to be
bloody it's david leech so
yeah um god i won't press you on this
i'll just say i cannot wait to see it uh
and i wish you nothing but the best and
congrats on being part of star wars
thank you thank you i just love being
part of star wars so i appreciate all
the support and definitely reach out to
consumer affairs and let them know if
you want an ethan bobblehead